[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream apologies to those
who are watching live earlier we had
some technical issues we believe they
are fixed so without further Ado we are
going to get on with live stream
150 not prime multiple different ways I
am Dr Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather
Hein and uh we've got uh quite a
a set of things to talk to you about
yeah uh there are some indications that
it's the end of everything
as we know it as we know it and a lot of
us don't feel fine no no no not
perfectly fine not at all so
unfortunately after technical problems
last week prevented us from doing a q a
the technical problems this week have
pushed us so far back that we're not
going to be able to do one this week
either we are going to actually do four
different streams next week so uh we are
going to have a live stream in the
normal time number 151 we're going to
follow up with the Q a which will have
potentially triple the number of
questions we never get to all the
questions we will get to as many as
possible beginning as always with
questions that have been voted on from
the Discord server that week on Sunday
of next week this is again the Saturday
after Thanksgiving and the Sunday after
Thanksgiving we are going to do a live
stream a special holiday gift Edition at
9 45 a.m Pacific on the Sunday after
American Thanksgiving for just an hour
talking about some of the products uh
that that we like without any sponsors
um and then we're going to follow that
with our private q a that's only for uh
patrons at my patreon for which the
question asking period is open right now
so if you are interested in being part
of that q a go over to my patreon and
join it and if you're interested in
asking questions on it that again that
question asking period is open right now
we really don't have a lot of fun with
those they are small enough that we're
able to watch the chat interact with the
chat pick up some questions from the
chat and and they're they're great so
we've got
what we think we're going to cover some
important stuff here today but we're
just going to do the one stream and next
week you get as much of us as you can
handle probably more of us than even we
can handle but four different streams
it's an entire Watershed of streams oh
wow okay right yeah kind of yeah sort of
it'll be close enough series of stream
moments Watershed yeah some I don't even
know how to do it I can't yeah I don't
know something extreme don't know but
it's gonna happen four different streams
if that's what you're looking for
exactly
um we are on YouTube and honestly the
chat is live on Odyssey right now and of
course we will be um you know you you
can be watching it or
uh or listening to it just about
anywhere that you might watch or listen
to such things
in Natural Selections this week my sub
stack I wrote about Portland Oregon the
city that we called home for four years
that we moved away from two months ago
and that I visited again last week last
week two weeks ago week and a half ago I
was there for the election and wrote
about some of what I saw there I called
it a love story a love letter and an
intervention
so I encourage you to go there also we
have as we've mentioned the last few
weeks a fantastic new store we are
working now with a couple out of the
middle of the United States who both run
the store and are also and also have the
print shop so all of the work that is
coming all of the products that are
coming out of our new store which is at
darkhorsestore.org is being printed on
site by them do you have someone to show
us here Zach
uh in just a second cool so we have uh
nothing new this week but we've got a
couple of new products in the last
couple of weeks we have the do not
affirm do not comply merchandise and
also we have this lie to a tyrant
uh where you've got uh some people
appearing to acquiesce to a tyrant but
doing everything they can to actually
not not comply and this is this is
necessary in these times so we've got
this wonderful artwork on a hoodie on a
shirt or two and we encourage you to go
there to darkhorsestore.org if you're
interested in such things
we are of course supported by our
audience we are not supported by YouTube
even though they put ads on our stuff
they demonetized us so any money that
they are making from uh from us we are
not getting any of that we of course
have patreons which we encourage you to
join and we also have a Discord which is
available at our patreons which has a
wonderful Community associated with it
they have honest and Congress on honest
and conversations that's not a thing
that's no no they they have honest
conversations about difficult topics
they have book clubs they have karaoke
they have virtual happy hours
and it's it's pretty great and happy
virtual hours
I'm pretty sure right well I think
there's another reason happiness is real
but the hours are also real
okay yeah it's the it's the happy hour
that's virtual it's not the happy or the
hour that's virtual it's the happy hour
which is some emergent property
involving drinks that are lower priced
and certain on account of them being
virtual
right yeah they should be extremely
economical at that level yes I would
think anyway that happens on the Discord
and yeah I don't know if they've had
that discussion probably they're above
that sort of thing oh you could
virtually drink yes indeed
um and we also have sponsors uh and this
is we we really do appreciate our
sponsors and we only take we only run
ads for sponsors uh who have products or
services that we actually can vouch for
either personally or have someone very
close to us who can do so so uh as as
usual we have three and let's go ahead
and get those going and you Brett are
first this week first up
uh our first sponsor this week is thesis
thesis makes no Tropics no Tropics are
nutri nutrients found in nature or in
the human body that enhance mental
performance in areas such as motivation
creativity mood memory and cognitive
processing they work best when combined
uh with taking care of yourself
generally which includes eating real
food moving your body often and getting
good sleep you're probably already using
anotropic
as one of the most commonly consumed
nootropics is caffeine but it is by far
the least exciting effective nootropics
allow people to optimize their focus
energy and mood based on the demands of
the day for some people no Tropics can
replace the Pharmaceuticals that are
often used to tackle problems like ADHD
thesis is unusual in the nootropic
market in taking a very personalized
approach they do not assume that what
works for your brother will work for you
or that what worked for you when you
were under a deadline for a dreadful
project will be the same thing that will
work for you when a spark of creativity
is necessary for a project you've been
dreaming of for years just as some
people become alert after a cup of
coffee and others can follow us asleep
so too all nootropics have different
effects on different people when thesis
first started out they blinded their
customers to what blend they were taking
and took careful data on how everyone
responded to the various Blends not
surprisingly different people responded
differently to different thesis Blends
now more than 2 500 customers and
millions of data points later thesis has
created a recommendation algorithm to
predict which blends of nootropic will
work best for any given customer the
process is simple go to their website
take a short quiz and they'll send you a
starter kit with four different blend
recommendations to try over the course
of a month
we've tried several Blends now
um uh we have not liked all of them but
have found several very intriguing
creativity Blends smooth things out a
bit and adds a little Clarity the logic
blend facilitates focus and your results
May Vary with fully personalized Blends
there's likely to be a thesis that is
right for you to get your own customized
thesis starter kit go online to
takethesis.com
Darkhorse take the quiz and use the code
Darkhorse at checkout for 10 off your
first box
our second sponsor this week is moink
that's moo plus oink m-o-i-n-k
an eighth generation farmer founded Mike
and is working hard to help save the
farm Family Farm and get its customers
access to the highest quality meat on
Earth did you know that 97 of the
chickens served in the U.S are dipped in
chlorine while Family Farms don't tend
to do that and certainly the meat that
you get from Mike doesn't do that
Mike delivers grass-fed and grass
finished beef and lamb pastured pork and
chicken and wild caught Alaskan salmon
right to your door
Mike Farmers Farm like our grandparents
did and as a result Mike meese
boink meat tastes like it should which
is to say delicious unlike the
supermarket might gives you total
control over the quality and source of
your food you choose the meat delivered
in every box like rib eyes chicken
breasts pork chops salmon fillets and
more and you can cancel anytime we love
everything about Mike the fact that the
meat is grass-fed and finished on small
farms the lovely Publications that come
along with it excuse me and of course
the meat itself right now in our
refrigerator we have Mike bacon and
ground pork and a turkey our
Thanksgiving is going to be delicious in
large part due to Mike
Shark Tank koi oh man
oh man hoist I I've got the oi sound now
from wink
uh Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
moink's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and I agree it is really
fantastic and actually we had some bacon
kale pasta last night made with white
bacon as well really fabulous keep
American farming going by signing up at
winkbox.com Darkhorse right now and
listeners of this show will receive free
filet mignon for a year that's one of
the best flame that's one year of the
best filet mignon you'll ever taste but
for only a limited time spelled
m-o-i-n-k box.com slash Darkhorse that's
mikebox.com Darkhorse
and our final sponsor this week is Ned a
CBD company that stands out in a highly
saturated CBD Market having a hard time
reading from my screen so despite what
our son would prefer I'm going to read
from the paper I'm gonna do it this way
though hide it okay Ned was started by
two friends who discovered that their
hyper modern lives were leaving from
feeling leaving them feeling empty
bewildered and disconnected something
about this way of life they say on their
website just wasn't working so they
started net
you can buy CBD products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but Ned's
Blends stand out I'm particularly fond
of their de-stress blend dense de-stress
blend is a one-to-one formula of CBD and
CBG made from the world's purest full
spectrum hemp and also features a
Botanical infusion of ashwagandha
cardamom and cinnamon CBG is a Botanical
nope see I just can't read today that's
the problem CBG is known as the mother
of all cannabinoids because of how
effective it is at combating anxiety and
stress by inhibiting the reuptake of
Gaba the neurotransmitter responsible
for stress regulation this combination
leaves me at least feeling a bit easier
with whatever comes my way
many of the CBD companies out there
Source their hemp from industrial farms
in China just like with low quality
alcohol however low quality CBD can have
undesired effects that is USDA certified
organic all of Ned's full spectrum hemp
oil is extracted from USDA certified
organic hemp plants grown by an
independent farmer named Jonathan in
Paonia Colorado
also Ned share's third-party lab reports
and information about who Farms their
products and their extraction process on
their site
these products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they are chock
full of Premium CBD and a full spectrum
of active cannabinoids terpenes
flavonoids and trichomes that's full
spectrum hemp oil nourishes the body's
endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance if you'd like
to give net a try a dark horse
Dark Horse listener only all dark horse
listeners get 15 off Ned products with
code Darkhorse visit hellonet.com Dark
Horse to get access that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d.com slash Dark Horse to
get 15 off thank you Ned for sponsoring
the show and offering our listeners a
natural remedy for some of life's most
common health issues
answers for the week man the dyslexia is
contagious in here Lord yeah that was
that's that's unlike me but there we go
that is very unlikely we did it it's
very like me uh and yet you didn't do it
I did it right off oh you didn't I did
too yeah oh I covered I'm glad I'm glad
it didn't show yeah yeah well you know
how to cover
I guess I do when it comes to reading
out loud which used to be one of my
greatest fears in life when when in
class they would come around and
everybody would read you know a
paragraph I used to not hear anything
anybody else said because I had to
figure out count ahead to which
paragraph I was gonna have to read and
then I had to read it three or four
times in order that I would not
embarrass myself and you're not alone
like I I didn't have that problem I I
always enjoyed reading until now until
today until today and uh and I didn't
relish it because I didn't like being on
the stage I didn't like having the
camera faced at me but um but I enjoyed
the Reading part
but certainly when we were professors I
saw how many students really dreaded
this and you haven't told me that story
I could tell which of them were doing it
and would would tend to give them a pass
so long as they could do something else
that demonstrated you know participation
interaction all of this and watching so
many other professors really just say
nope this is you know this is the thing
you have to do this is what you have to
do
when already the professors themselves
have chosen the kinds of tasks that work
for them and the ones that don't work
for them they aren't having the students
do and so it presumes that you want a
classroom that you are creating a
classroom which is entirely like you
which of course is not in line with what
we actually hope for for Humanity or
with what the you know the new woke
ideology would have us believe Educators
want either yeah and it doesn't work
very well in part because just by nature
of of selection professors tend to be
people who were good students themselves
and so to the extent that the things
that make some students not so great
don't look like the things that make
students great having all the professors
select the same kinds of activities
because it seems natural to them is just
a disaster indeed um I gotta tell you I
have now I had forgotten this but the
worst thing is when you miscount
no no you miscount the number of people
ahead and you read the wrong paragraph
three times and then you suddenly
discover oh no the person ahead of me is
reading the paragraph I thought I was
gonna have to read you're reading a
whole new paragraph you're thrown by the
thing it's uh so did the anxiety make
you enumerate or well you know I mean
remember I guess if you're not in a
circle if it's on top it can be tough
yeah it can be it can be tough or
somebody gets up and goes to the
bathroom or I don't remember exactly
what causes the tree to be one off but
it did happen more than once and uh
yeah yeah well
um
man did some things happen this week
really yeah so we're you're gonna you're
gonna start us off and we're gonna we're
gonna talk for a while about uh some of
the bigger issues and the
interconnections between them and much
of what we've been talking about for you
know for two and a half years now really
uh but we are I do hope to end with at
least a little bit on the research that
I was going to talk about last week
about cats domestic cats and their
perception yay or an A of human language
well I'm really excited about this I
still have not encountered this research
so I still don't know what's coming
um that's going to be awesome but yeah
all right so let's um let's talk about a
little of what has emerged and I believe
when we uh when we did our podcast last
week the FTX Scandal had already broken
but it was still very rapidly developing
and so we didn't you in fact mentioned
that you wanted to talk about it on air
and we didn't get to it and it all
seemed kind of like what what what what
is happening yeah what is it and you
know there's a lot of what is it still
going on in fact that's part of the
motivation for what I had planned for us
to do and so the way it's going to work
is this I want to draw a kind of picture
I want to connect some dots that I think
deserve to be connected and basically
Advance a model for where we are and
what these things have to do with each
other and I'm not saying that this model
is true and undoubtedly there are places
where it will be wrong or at least
imprecise but the question is is the
overall model more predictive of events
going forward than viewing all of the
pieces in isolation right that you know
in some sense a number of things which
we won't talk about this week maybe we
will get back to them next week have me
considering the question of how it is
that most people go about thinking and
reaching conclusions and there are a lot
of cases in which I'm watching people
um that I care about or have cared about
who have reached what I consider to be
uh
utterly absurd conclusions about things
and anyway thinking about how that
happens is is fascinating so in any case
one key thing is and it is increasingly
one of the one of the themes
um that we talk about here is you know
how
both how did people end up in such
different places and how do we reconcile
with them
there is that and there's also the
question
which I think is in some sense not it's
not a native question to us because the
answer is something that has emerged in
everything we've done but a question of
well how are you going to figure out
what's true in a chaotic environment in
which the facts themselves are being
hotly debated and are not agreed upon
where the authorities themselves
um are alleged to be compromised for
example how are you to figure out what's
going on well one thing that is
certainly true is if somebody's got a
model that's predictive then that's a
decent model and if it's more predictive
than some other model I don't care what
credentials went into that other model
or you know which three-letter agency is
backing it and whether in theory we
should be trusting those authorities the
answer is if it's not predictive it's
not predictive and so anyway the point
is we're going to talk about a model if
it's not predicted it's not predictive
but as you and we have also talked about
here before if you have no history of
making uh predictions that are borne out
by what what turns out to unfold then
you also shouldn't be someone who in
whom people are putting a lot of their
trust right right what you do when your
predictions are right what you do what
when they're wrong what happens to your
model as new information arises these
things are all critical and so anyway
maybe uh next week we can talk a little
bit about some of the lessons of the
present which I think are instructive
and kind of profound but for today what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at a model that connects up certain
things that you know in some sense if
you look at if you look at the news and
I don't even know what that means
anymore I don't know where it is that
we're supposed to go to find out what
the news is
Elon is making the argument that Twitter
in fact is a better source and you know
what kind of source is it even it's a
you know it's like a an endless room
full of people talking about things and
you can listen in and of course most of
what's said in any crowded room is
probably of no consequence at best
um but but one of the things one of the
ways that Twitter differs from any of
the mainstream media is that you get all
the biases in one place
that you you can receive you you can not
only get some some piece that's been
written by someone with some slant but
you can also get takes on it from the
left from the right from all over the
place but you can also get all the
pieces that are written on some
particular topic someone somewhere on
Twitter is going to have posted that and
that that means that it becomes more of
a Clearinghouse of news than anything
from CNN to
you know frankly I'm not I don't know
that fox is as far I'm not even sure
which one I'm doing here like I think
CNN is more ideological than fox in
almost every regard at this point I
can't speak to Fox generally I can say
that there are certain places on Fox
where one does tend to hear a
perspective which frankly doesn't strike
me as left or right it strikes me as
um uh it runs counter to the official
narrative
um and is often predictive yeah but you
know what you say I I hate to differ
with you already but what you're saying
should be true of Twitter but part of
what we're fighting over is whether or
not it will be true right whether or not
it's a place where you are allowed
post every perspective and it hasn't
been that way uh recently I mean the
number of people who have highly
predictive models who've been thrown off
of Twitter in recent times is staggering
right but that but that is reversing
yeah well right it is and it is Jordan
Peterson's back Babylon B is back to
name to name it two yep and then there
are a whole bunch that aren't none of
this isn't a person but right so I guess
it certainly Bears mention that the
absurdity of the doctor roller Gator
suspension
um continues for no obvious reason it's
such an absurd you know for those who
don't know it Dr Roller Gator was a
um an account that uh was satirical but
posted a lot of serious stuff and was
suspended I I believe the explanation
was for encouraging violence and what it
had done was it had suggested that
somebody slap somebody across the face
with a glove which is something that is
regularly posted on Twitter by other
accounts that don't get suspended and
this was nine months ago at least and it
hasn't been restored so in any case it's
um
Elon if you're watching go down on the
Twitter Dungeons and see if Dr
relligator isn't there and consider
freeing that account
um all right so let's
um
let's talk a little bit about the
various pieces that are in play and
build up a model and see whether it goes
anywhere
um
the first thing I wanted to talk about
was we have alleged
um that the blue team which is my term
for it because I don't like calling it
The Democratic party because the
Democratic party is something that has
had uh a an honorable role in history I
just think something's happened to it
and it's now that's now not what the
thing is it's behaving as something very
differently and treating it you know it
is like the family dog sorry the family
dog has gotten rabies right and the
point is thinking of the family dog once
it's got rabies as the family dog is the
wrong way to think about it that that
dog is now a serious problem and
so anyway
um the uh
the idea that the blue team is some
um new type of force is important and
it's something we've discussed uh and we
will come back to it in a second
I also wanted to
bring back up a concept that I heard
described very well by Peter Thiel I
don't know if it's his concept
originally or not it was just in a
speech that he recently gave but he
talked about there being two
um purposes for money and I thought this
was a very useful dichotomy and the one
purpose he described was as a means for
exchange which is to say you have some
money and you can use it to buy things
um and money still works well in this
way
but then there's this other way in which
money functions as a store of wealth
especially dollars the world's Reserve
currency right and the idea is that a
dollar even though it is a fiat currency
that basically has value because we
assert that it has value not because you
know a paper dollar doesn't have any
intrinsic value much less a you know a
decimal point on the screen but
nonetheless because the of the
durability of the United States its
currency is the world's Reserve currency
and has been so for many many decades
um and so anyway money functions as a
store of wealth right one thing you can
do if you have wealth is you can put it
into dollars and those dollars fluctuate
in terms of how much they're worth but
the point is there's some stability to
it and in fact other countries have
sometimes pegged their currencies to the
dollar because of that that stable value
and
what I'm increasingly realizing is that
that second
you would imagine that if that second
feature of money were to disintegrate
that it would take the first one with it
and this is less true than you would
imagine this is one of the curious
things about the present is there is
every reason to imagine that in fact the
store of wealth is failing to function
as a store of wealth that there's a
great deal of uncertainty about the
value of the dollar going forward in
large measure because we have basically
printed dollars as a way of getting out
of crises and that's a very limited
phenomenon but the store of wealth is
ever more
um suspect
and yet we're still using this object as
a means of Exchange in part because
something like crypto never figured out
how to be easy to use right crypto was
so hard to pay anybody with crypto that
um crypto worked as a store of wealth
but not as an exchange
yes exactly as an exchange modality
modality yeah now the funny thing is it
never really worked all that well as a
store of wealth either because it was so
volatile right and we have seen you know
that it worked better in that modality
in in in your telling of it in Teal's
second modality than in the first yeah
yeah it never worked as a modality of
exchange because in in part and this is
going to get to the the uh FTX part of
the story here in part because in order
to use it you had to go through an
exchange to get to Dollars and use those
for exchange so you know it was at best
a redundant and complexifying feature of
the environment
um
okay
but I want to call attention to
something that I think I haven't really
described here yet and it's something I
suspect is playing a huge hugely
important role in history at the moment
and uh I'm just gonna lay it out and you
uh you you help me get it to Clarity
okay
heard this yet uh what I call it the
time traveling money printer okay which
I know is not a name that calls anything
meaningful to mine yet but you'll see
why in a second nope time traveling
money printer everybody has gone through
the thought exercise of what would you
do if you had a time machine right and
almost no matter what your values are
you come up with some version of well if
I've got a time machine that goes
forward I could go and I could look at
stock prices a week from now a month
from now a year from now figure out what
was going to go up and then I could come
back in time and buy some of that figure
out what's going to go down I could
short that and so you could create a big
pile of wealth if you had a time machine
likewise if you can go backwards in time
you know you can go buy some Microsoft
or apple when they're nice and cheap and
you could become super wealthy by doing
this right
now
what I'm concerned about is that there's
actually a class of Elites that now
effectively has a time machine
and it doesn't have time travel in a
technical sense but it has another
mechanism of doing the same thing and it
has implications therefore for the value
of something like a dollar because if
somebody is capable of effectively
printing money of their own without
risking being arrested for
counterfeiting for example then the
point is they are robbing everybody who
holds dollars because there are more
dollars in circulation so every dollar
is worth less right so here's my claim
if you have effectively Insight on what
is going to happen historically speaking
and you share it then everybody quickly
picks up that insight and the markets
will correct for whatever is going to
happen right they will build that into
the price of whatever it is that you're
looking at if on the other hand you have
information about what's going to happen
historically and others don't have it
then you uniquely can position
yourselves for the change that is coming
create huge piles of wealth based on
what is effectively inside information
and thereby Rob everybody else who is
using this place to store their own
wealth and so let's take one example
that I think has become somewhat obvious
there is strong evidence that kovid was
circulating long before we and the
public became aware of we became aware
of it effectively at you know at the new
year of 2020 right tail end of January
was the earliest for almost everyone
tail end of January was the earliest for
for virtually everyone so you're a month
early already
it was it was March before you know sort
of widely understood many people were
aware in February Talent of January is
when for instance we became aware of it
I think the new year I don't think in
the new year more than a handful of
almost doesn't matter because let's put
it this way 2020 you're talking if you
are looking at information in
that's public and you put two and two
together and you say there's something
circulating and it could affect the
world and other people are slow to
realize it that's legitimate that's
Insight that's driving it on the other
hand there's a strong evidence
that the virus was circulating
um at the Wuhan military games in
September of 2019. September October I
think it was September but it doesn't
matter the point is long before the
public got any warning that there might
be something worth paying attention to
in this space
now here's the question
who knew
right if nobody knew if it was
circulating and it just didn't dawn on
anybody to test for it or figure out
that there was a pattern okay then we're
all in the same place
if on the other hand
certain people knew what was coming and
instead of sharing that information
publicly what they did was position
themselves so that predictable things
would cause them to become wealthy you
know you can short uh stocks for let's
say cruise ships which are going to take
a terrible hit right I don't you know
you you could see some things that would
obviously be elevated yeah
um you might know who had you know
viable vaccine technologies that might
become quickly relevant who's to say but
the point is if you had inside
information in September October of 2019
that there was a great uh contagious
disease that was going to spread as a
pandemic
you might well be in a wonderful
position to effectively print money and
the key to it is you can't move in time
but you can slow other people down in
terms of how quickly they realize what's
coming so that by the time they are
saying hey maybe cruise ships are going
to take a hit the point is you've
already you've already shorted that
stock right
so the basic point is well is there a
game afoot
in which
instead of
um trying to read the tea leaves better
instead of using expertise to figure out
which things are undervalued and to
Arbitrage those markets that instead the
game is to delay the dawning of insight
on the public and turn them into a
never-ending sea of what would an
economic terms be called greater fools
right
um and if that happens right if it
happens once then the point is you'll
see a fortune created and it will rob
everybody else to a small degree but if
it becomes systematic right then it
raises the question of well then what is
what are dollars right if somebody is
able to make dollars when they want to
by being ahead of everybody else because
they know what's coming why are they
ahead of everybody else because they
slow them down in the recognition of
these patterns and the point is well
that's not a store of wealth from the
point of view of most people that's a
scheme in which some people make great
fortunes and others uh slowly have their
wealth drained away right so slowing
down the awareness
of people can look a lot of a lot of
ways
and I think you're going to go to a
couple of these places but is that where
you're going next that's exactly it this
is why I think we are fighting over
what kind of place Twitter is going to
be for example right so the idea is if
we and the public have a place in which
to do some truth seeking if universities
still function to seek truth if
journalists are still pursuing truth
right then we have mechanisms that we
can use to figure out what's coming too
if we can hobble those institutions
right and so the point is well there's
no what is the newspaper you would go to
to figure out just the basic facts of
what's taking place so you could begin
to build a model of your own if we don't
have that because there is no newspaper
that isn't uh a partisan rag at this
point right if we don't have scientists
who will tell us the truth of some uh
important economically relevant field
what we have is people spreading
narratives then the point is well that
creates a landscape in which this game
can unfold again and again and so
viewers of Darkhorse will be well
familiar with the idea that zero is a
special number
and this is really I'm arguing this is
at least one good reason why zero is so
special is that it creates that
um a landscape in which wealth can be
drained away from most people who have
stored it in things like dollars to
those who have a privileged position as
a result of the fact that sense making
has now become it is descended into
noise
can I just share one short paragraph
sure right here I want to share a little
bit more later but this piece that
probably I don't actually don't know if
you've seen it but probably many of our
me our audience has
by Jeffrey Tucker at The Brownstone
Institute called the covid crypto
connection the Grim Saga Saga wow I just
can't read today
covered crypto connection the Grim Saga
of FTX and Sam bankman is it free for
Friday it's freed okay I'm just start
over
piece published in The Brownstone
Institute by Jeffrey Tucker this week
the covered crypto connection the Grim
Saga of FTX and Sam Bachman freed
uh one paragraph is I will tell you
rights Tucker what infuriates me about
these billions in fake money and deep
Corruptions of politics and science for
years now my anti-lockdown friends have
been hounded for being funded by
supposed dark money that simply doesn't
exist many Brave scientists journalists
attorneys and others gave up great
careers to stand for principle exposing
the damage caused by the lockdowns and
this is how they have been treated
smeared and displaced
that this is exactly it and this is this
is why I'm raising this this week is
that I think what has happened is the
FTX Scandal has allowed us to Glimpse
something and it ain't the first time
this has happened either in fact I would
Point people to the Enron situation
right the Enron situation was
eight jaw-dropping case of fraud but it
was also connected to the red team
right it was connected to the Bush
Administration in ways that we never
figured out and I believe what happens
is you Glimpse the tip of the iceberg
and then we cannot help but use the
tools from the past to try to assert
what the object is you know what is FTX
oh well it was obviously a fraudulent
Exchange in which people put their money
in and they thought that that money
existed in uh some place that they could
access it but in fact inside of FTX
there was no Safeguard against them
using it personally against them
investing it recklessly right oh my God
it was jaw dropping but that ain't the
half of it right in fact I would argue
that that's really even the cover story
that in some sense what you've got is
the blue team which is a racket has
mechanisms for doing things it has
there's a machine that we cannot see
that shapes history and that machine has
mechanisms for shunting large amounts of
money into places right if we say oh
that's money laundering no it includes
money laundering but the point is this
is really the shaping of History it is
not in any way an accident in my opinion
that the FTX Scandal seems to touch
Ukraine and energy policy where there is
now a war raging
where the bidens have perverse
incentives where uh the information that
was Unearthed about Hunter Biden's
laptop was a silenced prior to an
election including the censoring of the
New York Post right in other words there
is some engine that knows where its
bread is buttered
and it is capable of making things
happen right it is capable of slowing
down the dawning of information about
Hunter Biden's laptop so it does not
play a decisive role in the waning days
of the 2020 election campaign for
example
right I don't I still don't think we
understand why Ukraine shows up as a
place that Hunter Biden was making a
fortune that made no sense where his
internal emails suggested Joe Biden is
involved and there is now a war raging
and we have you know the president of
Ukraine is a hero but if you scratch the
veneer you discover that's not what's
going on there there's some story that
involves Ukraine and energy in the
bidens which we don't know that involves
the blue team and its ability to shape
history so we'll think it's one thing
even though it's something else there is
I agree with you I don't know that
anything is yet revealed on this front
um so I feel like
it is a stronger position and it makes
more sense to to back up and to actually
say what what is this what what what are
we talking about I don't feel like I I
don't think you actually said like what
is
what is this what is a Sam bankman freed
and what is FTX so like can we can we
back way up and say that and then talk
about the thing that we really do know
in this case which yes
not only do we know more about it
because it's something that we talked
about and that actually this we got
tentacled by this thing directly and so
yes we do know more about it but um
that's not what we're talking about it's
because it's actually clear we there is
a connection between the denigration of
ivermectin yes I said it here on YouTube
um as a possible treatment and
prophylaxis for covid and FTX and and
team blue right whereas Ukraine
Underpants laptop like probably actually
right like I I think yeah but we don't
know and that hasn't come out yet
whereas the funding by FDX of
anti-ivamectin research is now known
it's a lead bear we have to so I agree
with you we don't know what what Ukraine
is doing in the story we don't
understand that
what is FTX there is an official
description of whatever let's let's go
there so the official description is
that it was a crypto exchange and those
who have used crypto know that
effectively you have to if you want some
crypto right how do you get some well
you have to take dollars and you have to
make it into crypto somehow right so you
have to you have this electronic wallet
and you have to get some crypto into it
you have to buy crypto and the way you
do that is you use an exchange now the
problem and this has been clear for
those involved in crypto for quite some
time the problem is it isn't obvious
what you are getting when you go to a
crypto exchange like coinbase or like
FTX and you use your credit card or you
make a bank transfer
that gets you some crypto do you own
particular units of crypto or is this an
IOU where you have put money into this
thing and as long as it remains solvent
you can take that money out but that it
is vulnerable because there are no
particular tokens or fractions of tokens
that in fact are yours it's it's like
the distinction between having a gold
bar in your hand and having an IOU for a
gold bar paper Metals versus actual
Metals right
and so the problem is that in order to
use crypto in order to get crypto in
order to trade crypto the exchanges were
the best way to do this but the security
of that apparatus was we now know
effectively non-existent right because
that money seems to have evaporated out
of FTX and was spent in all kinds of
crazy ways including a personal loan to
Sam uh bankman freed for a billion
dollars uh you know things that make no
sense sometimes you need some cash
that's true
um
but
so that's the official story of what
this is this is a an exchange that went
bad that was badly managed yeah but and
Enron is exactly the right analogy well
Enron is an interesting case because
there is one fundamental difference
between Enron and what we see at FTX
what's up Enron existed it was a company
it did things and then it became a fraud
okay it went it it liquidated its
business and it went into fraud full
time yeah but the point is it had been a
business and one of the things that is
yeah wasn't there am I misremembering
wasn't there like they had either a
whole building or a bunch of floors on a
building and there's like one floor that
was where all the fraudulent stuff was
taking place and like you don't go there
if you don't want to see or was that a
different story no it's you I think you
have the story uh not quite exactly
right but so there was the point is that
there was real work going on there it
had been right and then increasingly the
Returns on real work were just so small
compared to the fraud that the fraud
took over Enron right
um and in fact Enron started perfecting
fraud and it used techniques where
effectively it learned
that if you told people under your
employee bring me a profit and I don't
care how you do it if you bring me a
profit I'll make you rich if you uh fail
I'll fire you and so people are
innovating all kinds of ways to make a
paper profit that isn't a real profit
and the point is they get rewarded
because in fact the higher ups don't
want their fingerprints on it but what
they want is a company that looks like
it has a tremendous value because of
course that can be turned into real
wealth in markets Etc so
Enron was a business that became a fraud
FTX appears to have been
these weren't serious people when you
look at what they were doing on the
inside first of all they were just flat
out Liars right and we will get to the
connection with
um
with effective altruism which is a
philosophy but the basic point was even
at the way in the way that they
represented themselves this was nonsense
from the beginning right there wasn't a
business this was this was a con and you
know it's funny one of the things that
is revealed by this is that certain
elements of the the elite architecture
are not ready to just surrender to the
idea that this was just a fraud you know
the New York Times is experimenting with
uh resurrecting Sam bankman freed
you know as the you know
well-intentioned CEO of a company that
got out of hand or something like that
but this is really the wrong the wrong
way to look at it you have a non-serious
entity and in part it's obvious that
this is non-serious because it came out
of nowhere right something fueled the
belief that this thing was a real entity
so that it skyrocketed out of nowhere
into this hugely valuable property that
was heralded by people as you know
deeply insightful and you know forging
the way and
um and it was nonsense
so I I don't see uh rapid Ascent as
inherently evidence of being fueled from
outside sources no that the question is
well what did they bring to the table
that was new that caused them to be so
valuable
right one of a handful of crypto
exchanges I'm I'm still Manning without
I'm trying to steal my without very much
information I don't really understand
what they claim to be doing I don't know
the land of crypto at all really
um but you know one of relatively few
crypto exchanges and
um frankly probably one of the only ones
that was explicitly on the ideological
left
well I don't know that I don't know the
ideological left much matters what
matters in terms of having been able to
attract people right I mean bankman
freed is now famously on some kind of
record if if we are to believe
this you know to take a step aside for a
moment this this Vox article right
published by uh what's her name I think
it's Kelsey Piper yeah um oh I guess I
can't show my screen here but I can read
to you so what Kelsey Piper does so
Kelsey Piper who had come to us to get
to talk about Ivermectin back a year and
three months ago or so something like
that
um
also in the effect of altruism and
rationalist Community right and a staff
writer for Vox and in this article that
she publishes in Vox a couple days ago
she does acknowledge that a grant that
they were about to receive that Vox or
something like something there was about
to receive from either FDX or the
bankman freed Family Foundation has been
you know put on hold so that you know
it's all entangled and you know there's
this appearance of transparency now kind
of ish but not really but what she says
she's doing in this piece mostly is
basically just screenshotting a DM
conversation that she has with Sam
beckmanfried on Twitter on the night of
I think it's November 15th at the point
that he's already in the Bahamas and
just a couple things that he says and
these have been well described in places
um but he says
we play this dumb game we woke
westerners play
this dumb game we woke westerners play
where we say all the right shibliffs and
so Everyone likes us
so there's there's that so that like I
don't know what I don't know what theirs
that means I'm saying there's that there
is that is the game that he was playing
whereby he got left leaning investors
from Hollywood from the media from
places who have been taught to be
hesitant about crypto because oh that's
on the right those might be Nazis right
so you know crypto seems like this
dangerous place because it is somehow
identified not as with the left whereas
this exchange was so that's one thing
well but then that's a prediction which
is that the value of FTX arises because
left-leaning people were using it as
their exchange to access crypto yeah I
don't think there's any evidence that
the uh the flow through FTX was
inherently left leaning that is the
prediction I'm making and I and I yeah I
predict that will be true I don't know
that we'll find out but I guess I guess
given all of the big names that are
still defending it and are still
associated with it are on the left
that's I I guess I thought I I guess I
don't think that's a very far out
prediction at all well but I actually
think the opposite would be very natural
if this thing was effectively conning
people who were left leaning so that
they would use it instead of for example
coinbase then you would imagine that the
left would be utterly irate at having
been taken for a ride by a clear fraud
somebody who in his public Persona was
despite being a billionaire many times
over still driving a Toyota Corolla
because he didn't really care for the
Finer Things in life while at the same
time he was you know hanging out in the
Bahamas in a you know 40 million dollar
estate effectively mocking those who
believed that he was actually Frugal but
it's it's one more of these you know
what's on the outside of the package
it's not what's on the inside and over
and over and over again the the woke
left just
takes it hook line Sinker just says okay
if I'm in a little bit I'm in all the
way I'm like I'm I'm gonna I'm Gonna
Keep on down that line let me just share
the other screenshot from this piece
that that Kelsey Piper reports on yeah
before we go back to what you're talking
about
um he says
everyone goes around pretending the
perception reflects reality it doesn't
so that's his dismissal of the
postmodernism that all of his stuff
seems to embrace because he's on he's in
that ideological court and then he says
some of this decade's greatest heroes
will never be known and some of its most
beloved people are basically shams
so it's possible this isn't what it
seems at all
but no one is claiming the guy is dumb
and you know why he would have this
conversation with some someone from Vox
you know as as his entire Empire is
failing I don't know
but that sounds like a an admission
of recognition
of guilt
to me
yeah it's it's too dumb to be believed I
mean the guy is in so much trouble that
the idea that he is going to speak off
the cuff to a reporter and it's just
going to turn out to emerge in public I
don't believe Kelsey and I don't believe
him I I think that this is an attempt to
uh carry some kind of sympathy there was
going to be absolutely no way to pretend
that he had not been
um you know hypocritical with respect to
his values but in some so I I think that
this is
um
it's a false portrayal of what's
actually going on and our interaction
with Kelsey Piper and the way she dealt
with Ivermectin and what we know about
how she's uh interacted with
um people we know well over the same
topic uh I don't I don't trust this at
all I think we're supposed to believe
that that conversation took place and he
was careless and she's a little bit
ruthless and this is the internal
dialogue but I think it's bull
um
but
we also know you know it's like you're
um hypothesis and your prediction is
that this thing was fueled by the fact
that it sounded like it had the right
values and therefore became valuable
because those people with wealth who
held those values were yeah hypothesis
is there are a lot of people with wealth
on the left who want to invest in crypto
but they couldn't bring themselves to
because it seemed a little creepy right
icky or right-leaning or something and
that FDX arrived
um being all vegan or something and they
went there but we also see little
glimpses of circularities uh inside the
funding of FTX where
VCS who have invested in FTX are then
invested in by FTX so the point is
something is using this engine it is
sanitizing it it is infusing it with
cash and that that I don't know that
that may be true but that seems
unrelated to the first point well my
point is I don't I think it is a mistake
to view this as you know an organ
organically ascendant property that
brought something to the table that was
so valuable that it suddenly was this
you know billion dollar player oh I
don't think that's true
I don't think that my hypothesis
requires that is therefore how FTX
became the PowerHouse that it was I
think that to the degree that it had a
lot of investors a lot of people who
were who were
buying on that exchange that the vast
majority of the people who were buying
an FDX were were woke Lefty so you're
talking about people who are using it
yeah and then there's this other
question about why investors bought
anything about it because its internal
structure didn't make any sense because
it was incredibly Baroque they had a org
chart that was insane in spite of the
fact that it was a very new entity we
can we see as you know I'm a fan of org
charts yeah is that is that we have seen
it yes and it's Baroque but then there's
no board of directors and any of the
checks that you would expect to be
ensuring that the thing was properly run
on the inside and then you know you look
at FTX and its partner Alameda and
you've got a you know it's almost a
literally incestuous group of people who
do not speak like they know what they're
talking about
um so the point is it has the sense it
is very much like enron's phony trading
floor right yeah and that's yeah I I
think that's it and I think you know you
know
the the conversation that Kelsey Piper
reports with Sam bammon free you know
after midnight and from the Bahamas a
few days ago
um but
you know there is in there true or not
they sort of
um you know she's like didn't you say
that um that FDX never did X she's and
he's like yeah technically that's true
because it immediately went to
Elementary
and yeah I may have that backwards so
maybe Alameda I said Alameda never did
and that was FDX like I don't remember
which way it goes I don't I don't know
all of the machinations here but it was
that sort of like yes well strictly
speaking literally speaking what I said
was true because I knew that you no one
could ask me the question that they
wanted me to answer that's that's it
right like you know I can I can speak I
can speak truth and my conscience is
clear if I think that the only thing
that I need for a clear conscience is
did I in fact ask the literal question
they
did I answer the literal question they
asked given that I created an entire
thing behind me that no one can uh guess
at and therefore no one can ask me the
right questions about it yeah until
until now let's put it this way that's
that's a game that always gets played
you have to ask exactly the right
question
um uh or nobody will make even the most
basic inference about what you're really
trying to ask and give you an answer
that actually makes any sense
um but let's actually get to the
ivermect and stuff because I think this
is the place where we've seen the
clearest glimpse so far of what this
really was
um and let's be careful about what what
we actually know okay so the interesting
fact is that the together trial which
was heralded this trial was
um
heralded as the largest randomized
controlled trial of the effectiveness of
ivermectin against covid uh ever at the
time it was released it was released in
a bizarre way where we were given the
result the supposed negation of the
utility of ivermectin six months before
the paper ever emerged so we were shown
effectively a slide from a talk that
claimed that they had tested Ivermectin
and it didn't work and the largest
randomized controlled trial which we are
told
erroneously is the gold standard of
evidence but nonetheless we were told
this and then we had to wait six months
to see the paper
so there were all of these headlines
that said what the result of the
randomized controlled trial had been no
ability to check whether the methodology
made any sense whether the trial was in
fact underpowered the way Pharma
typically makes these trials so that
they will show no efficacy of efficacy
of a competing compound to something
that they wish to sell we couldn't see
that and then the paper finally emerges
and lo and behold
a whole new set of headlines emerges as
if there's been some second major
randomized controlled trial but in fact
it's the same one the methods section is
opaque so even figuring out what they
did is uh extremely difficult I would
advise people to look at alexandros
marinos's uh Publications on the
together trial it's jaw-dropping what
they did
it was underpowered it was underpowered
in a way that was utterly systematic and
cryptic you know in other words they had
a uh cut off among other things they had
a cut off for uh weight and so that they
increased the dosage with weight which
makes sense and then they had a cut off
at which they stopped increasing it so
yeah they didn't have a cut off for
weight of the participants the
participants could be as obese as they
needed to be but the dosage stopped
increasing at some weight of the of the
participants in the trial right and so
because covid is serious proportionally
to weight the idea of under-dosing
people as you know as they get you know
if you cap the dosage at a per kilogram
uh level and then as people add
kilograms you stop increasing the dosage
you are systematically underdosing
people the heavier they are the more
underdosed they are that is exactly a
cryptic way to say oh the dose was high
it was x per kilogram
um the obese people are more likely to
have been badly affected by covet in the
first place the obese people have been
underdosed for the possible treatment
and so they are least likely to be
positively affected by the treatment
also being cut excuse me the people most
likely to have a bad outcome from coven
right so this was not the only way in
which the trial was underpowered but
it's one of them uh also I should point
out that the trial promised to release
their data and still has not done so but
in any case you've got this trying to
follow the science under these
circumstances yeah you you you can
follow the headline is about all you can
do
um but in any case you have this trial
appallingly run
um that FTX shows up as a actually Zach
can you show my tweet on this
yep
so Zach is going to show a tweet in
which I've compiled a few screenshots of
relevant items here
um so can you zoom in yeah zoom in on
that first one
uh
well so the first screenshot that uh
Zach is going to try to zoom in on here
is a screenshot on the together trials
uh website in which they reveal FTX as a
funder
um so this is actually the second one
can we go right yep yeah so go back so
Twitter is not Twitter is not working
very well oh there you go so here it is
funded by FTX now let's be very clear do
we have a date on that can you read it
Brett uh Zach uh no date no date okay
the FTX funding of the together trial
arrives late after the Ivermectin arm
now that does not that this is going to
come back it's interesting okay so the
funding of the together trial by FTX is
after the Ivermectin arm
after it's completed yep
um now uh go to the next screenshot yeah
okay here you can see this is a news
release from May 16 2022 the FDX
Foundation supports the global expansion
of the trial of the Year award-winning
together trial so the together trial won
something called the trial of the Year
from the FTX foundation and was awarded
18 million dollars in funding and
purchase commitments
now
it is not a hundred percent obvious what
is going on here
but 18 million dollars is a huge amount
of money in the realm can you just put
that back up for a second Zach so I
haven't seen this before and I was just
reading sorry yeah uh
uh so it's it's the society for clinical
trials which is an existing society that
I had never heard of before has an
existing a word so this is not a new
this is not a new award being announced
this year but this but the together
trial wins the society for clinical
trials award this year and they say
um that they award it based on five key
criteria but do they say what those five
key criteria are here they don't okay
that's what I wanted to see it's not
it's not listed here I don't know what
they are so
we can't know what this is but we do
know that a huge payment 18 million
dollars in fact flowed to people who had
generated a trial that systematically
sabotaged Ivermectin
in a way that was predicted
and that turns out to have been the case
we can't see the data but we can see the
methods and to the extent that we can
reverse engineer what they did it is
exactly what you would do if you wanted
to demonstrate that Ivermectin didn't
work in spite of the fact that it does
okay so the question is what role is
this play well The Blue Team clearly has
doubled down a hundred times on the idea
that there that Ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine do not work for covid
they have doubled down on the idea that
the right way to address covid is with
the so-called coveted vaccinations and
so what you have is a cabal advancing a
story about what does and doesn't work
that story is being
sanitized and supported by garbage
scientific work that is then rewarded at
an extraordinary level by exactly this
fraudulent entity that we have just
discovered has been doing the bidding of
the blue team and uh of the effective
altruism movement and at the point that
Vox
appears pretends to appear
to be waking up to some of what it has
been complicit in
that Kelsey Piper story is number one on
the voxide uh head uh website right now
but number four uh most popular stories
on the Vox website right now when the
Kelsey Piper story supposedly revealing
the depths of the depravity and
awareness of Sam mcmen freed is
headlined going home for the holidays
boost mask and test beforehand
so that's the same that's the same cabal
pretending that you know I either
there's awareness or there isn't right
um if if this is still the stuff being
published on Vox at the same moment
there's awareness over here about some
of some of the tentacles that are all
wrapped up in one another and if you
pull on one you're gonna find something
really really bad inside you know
what what could be big enough
to wake it all up to wake up this beast
and to stop having an article
recommending that you boost before you
go see your family
for instance well one thing and one of
the reasons that I wanted to have this
conversation on Dark Horse today is I
think it is really important not to jump
to conclusions about what some
scandalous entity in front of us is in
other words I think we missed the boat
with Enron I think we figured out what
was going on in the Enron building but
we didn't figure out what role it was
playing in Civilization okay
I think we were in danger of doing the
same thing here that the idea is we will
accept something something you know
salacious about what was taking place at
FTX and we will wag our fingers at them
and we will fail to understand what its
real role in the universe was
so Enron is when late 90s early Arts I
don't actually remember you want to look
it up quickly Zach
um
yeah
um Google Enron you'll immediately find
um you just sort of when when it all
goes to to hell
um I think one of this is not then
whatever it was it's it's a couple
decades
2001. okay uh so oh right after 9 11.
Wikipedia you know I think Wikipedia
isn't wrong about that level of History
yet
um
we're
21 years later this is not then but
I know that it felt to those of us who
were still
dedicated Democrats at the time
like and you said Enron was a was a red
team failure right that was that was
that appeared to be and I haven't seen
anything that suggests that it was that
it wasn't orchestrated by and
perpetuated by and you know and done and
done by a bunch of people who would have
claimed to have been on red on on team
red as it were and
there was I'm sure a fair bit of
smugness and self-satisfactory backpack
back padding padding backpacking back
padding on on the part of various
Democrats who might have been doing
something similar but weren't or weren't
discovered doing it
and part of what we're seeing here is
well of course the other side would do
it and it's 21 years later and they
learned some things and there's more
technological capacity and it's worse
it's it's going to take out a whole lot
more than Enron did
and can we do something more than having
team red be smug and team blue be in
denial which I think is kind of what
happened with Enron well team red was in
denial and team blue was smug and it's
like okay great I think this is
it's worse than that sure
the
we have looked at the tip of an iceberg
we don't know what the iceberg is but we
have looked at the tip of the iceberg
and this iceberg is involved in things
that the blue team holds dear
it is involved in a case that we know
well in
apparently rewarding people for having
run a fantastic randomized controlled
trial that was in fact an appalling
randomized controlled trial that just so
happens to have concluded that a drug
that everybody swears doesn't work they
concluded that it didn't work when the
trial was set up in a way that would
guarantee that outcome
so
the obvious question is
in the absence of things like
universities
science journals
newspapers truth seeking apparatus that
works in the Public's interest in the
absence of that in the total vacuum of
the ability of some institution to seek
truth on our behalf
something is engineering the appearance
of X Y and Z in other words there's a
price point if you want something to be
a fact iremacin doesn't work you want
that to be a fact that's going to cost
you it could be a fact
but it's going to cost you right it's
going to cost you 18 million bucks well
18 million bucks that's a bargain
compared to the money that will be made
if Ivermectin doesn't work that's a lot
more than 80 million bucks oh no doubt
that that award is a tiny piece of it I
mean if if we're going to play that game
there you know there's also the
purchasing of all sorts of cheap
offshore accounts to flood social media
with snarky comments about how people
advocating forever making or killing
people right right you know there's you
know there's all sorts of little
branches of this that each cost some
amount of money sure and I don't mean to
suggest that 18 million bucks is enough
to do it what I mean to suggest is we
knew and we said at the time if somebody
wants to go back through those
broadcasts they will find we know that
we are facing some incredibly powerful
thing we can feel what it is doing in
and around this story we don't know what
it is we don't know how it works but
that it exists is something that is
apparent if you have attempted to sort
out the truth of these repurposed drugs
for example so that thing it turns out
lived in part at FTX it lived in part at
Vox it explains the odd behavior
and the thing that people prediction the
Atlantic received some FTX related money
well the question is how deeply are you
going to have to dig and how does this
all work and I will point out that I
have argued that there are a couple
different ways that this thing could
work one is it could hire people to
write garbagey stories to not put two
and two together and Advance their
argument in the Atlantic or the New York
Times or whatever the other way
is that it could basically cultivate
Freelancers
in other words one thing that could
explain something like the FTX trial is
that you've got a bunch of people who
understand ha
power really doesn't want Ira mechanic
Ivermectin to compete with whatever the
official
treatments are
and so
if you produce a trial that does that if
you figure if you function like an
underling at Enron where the superiors
don't want to know what you're doing
they what they want you to do is make
the company look valuable on paper right
if you took that same approach inside of
Science and you said well power seems to
want this drug not to work and so what
kind of
what kind of work do you have to do to
suggest that maybe it will find me and
reward me for doing that right so the
point is that after the fact award could
be
the evolution of a system of you
freelance either in journalism or on
Twitter as we've seen a bunch of you
know self-appointed uh fraud uh Seekers
on Twitter who are interested in fraud
on one side enough that they will invent
it where it doesn't exist and not the
least bit interested in fraud coming
from the other side that's a conspicuous
fact sure are those people looking to be
rewarded by something and does that
thing look like this entity that we've
now had a glimpse inside of right is
this is the purpose of all of the money
flowing into this thing basically that
it can reward and facilitate things uh
which have a value to you know the team
that's funding it right in other words
laundering doesn't really cover that
right this is something beyond that is
this an incentivizing engine right that
is supposed to look like a business to
explain why it has all of these
resources but maybe it's something
beyond that
um I think the last piece of the puzzle
we need to talk about is uh effective
altruism because it shows up in the
story I think a lot of people don't even
know what effective altruism is
and it's worth it's worth connecting
that that piece of it
so effective altruism is like
um the 2.0 version of rationalism right
so rationalism was a
school of thought that I thought had
some promise to it I never uh loved it
because there's a way in which it
um
I think you know it believes it's got a
method for being fully rational and it
doesn't understand that ration that yes
in theory ultimately that's the way it
should be but how you get from Quadrant
a where you're rational to quadrant B
where you're rational when the
intervening space is something you don't
really understand you know you may want
to relax the bounds of rationality a
little bit because you're you may
ultimately be more rational in the end
if you do that right yeah it assumes too
much stasis in both initial conditions
and
and what can evolve in the interim yeah
that said you know it did some things
really right right it uh focused on a
Bayesian understanding of complex
systems which uh is laudable it is the
source ultimately of Steel Manning which
is a great uh technique that many of us
have adopted
um so anyway rationalism is there's good
and bad but it was largely good but at
the point that it morphs into effective
altruism
wow is there a bunch to say about what's
wrong with that idea now there's one
thing right with it I will argue which
is that
what we as evolutionists know is that
altruism pure altruism altruism does not
function it is a self-unstable strategy
right and that is because something that
behaves truly altruistically
um is in a wonderful position to be
taken advantage of by something that uh
is not altruistic so the Free Riders
Drive the altruist to Extinction
and to the extent that the effective
altruists have a point their point is
well maybe we can architect around them
right maybe there's a way of
architecting around it however
when it effectively becomes is a
a nightmare of a kind that history
periodically sees
right so
um
first it is worth thinking a little bit
about utilitarianism
utilitarianism being the philosophy that
says we should pursue that which
produces the greatest good for the
greatest number which sounds extremely
laudable until you start pressure
testing it and you realize that there
are certain things that it puts you in
danger of right
for example slavery what if you have a
case in which enslaving people does a
large amount of harm to a small number
of people but the net good is positive
for the society that does the enslaving
well
utilitarianism would defend it but
that's obviously immoral so the point is
you don't want to you don't want to
embrace utilitarianism at the level of
algorithm because it will drive you into
some places that we should never go
effective altruism is even one step more
dangerous
right because there's a there's a
recursion question right there's a
question of
um
over what scale are you trying to do
good and because ultimately the the
biggest scale and the most long-standing
scale are the places where the maximum
amount of good can be done effectively
it becomes an excuse for anything at a
lower scale
and the
I mean the correct parallel I believe is
um it's like indulgences on steroids
right indulgences having been the uh
the
what would it be the program of the
Catholic church that allowed
wealthy people to effectively buy the
right to commit a sin for money because
the amount of good that the church could
do with the money
uh was supposed to exceed the harm done
by the sin right now that thing resulted
in the splitting up of Catholicism and
the birth of protestantism
um because it was such a Scourge the
idea that wealthy people should be able
to buy their
um you know the good graces of God
through this mechanism is obviously an
absurdity and a Corruption of the church
and the point is effective altruism has
the same flavor right and that flavor it
is not really clear I don't see the
connection yet what's the flavor
um
let's look at uh Sam bankman freed
that's okay Sam backman freed
was a fraud
who
um took money from people
and uh did not treat it with the proper
care that he should have either the
investors or the money of people who use
the exchange sure
but he created a an entity that was very
powerful
that is arguably defensible if you know
what in the end the wealth evaporated so
that's not defensible but that could be
because the claim was that the entity
was going to do larger good in the world
than any individuals were going to be
able to do right and this is one of
these cases where okay the
um the loophole is as big as you need it
to be sure any evil at all can be
ostensibly Justified on the basis that
it is necessary to fuel some larger good
that will be done later at larger scale
right and so the basic point is you want
complete freedom from morality well you
can get there through effective altruism
because it's in no way bounded right so
it therefore removes every constraint
yeah
yeah I'm no no pay no attention to my
actions my intentions are good and I've
and I'm just I'm gaining power so that I
can push all those intentions in the
right direction yep they'll gladly pay
you Tuesday for a hamburger today
um and the you know this also raises the
question about what they will do
as the bankruptcy of that mode is
literally literally and figuratively
revealed in other words
um to what extent is effective altruism
having a you know
a moment of reflection about what's
wrong with what it believes and to what
extent is it behind the scenes
um conspiring to keep itself going
because it doesn't actually think that
anything here has been demonstrated
other than some you know Bad Business
calls that caused it's a good thing to
blow up so
in any case
there are a lot of messages in this
whole uh picture here one of them has to
do with
um
do-gooders right effective altruism is
like a kind of uh
wokeness for
what would I even call them awokeness
for people who aspire to being
intellectuals
um and it has all sorts of outgrowth
it's willing to
partner apparently with those who would
sabotage a good drug in the middle of a
pandemic
um well here we get back to your point
that you called what time traveling
money printer money printer right
it's not
one thing that you could do
is is create history and know what
you're creating and just be ahead of the
game because you know what's going to
happen because you're making it happen
and another thing you can do is make
sure that the thing that could
send you in One Direction like oh
actually this is this is a treatable
disease it doesn't get discovered by you
know
funding and favoring and you know buying
accounts and voices that basically make
sure that no one who you know you would
want to have at a cocktail party would
ever think that a horse dewormer could
possibly be something you could use tree
covered with isn't that so funny so
funny so you know there's there's a lot
of there are a lot of branches of that
of that attack on this one particular
drug and on several of them really and
on the individuals like Dr Corey and you
know so many others who are saying yeah
actually this is a oh never mind right
like I'm gonna I'm gonna go I for
instance Dr Corey I'm gonna go and treat
people privately and You're Gonna Keep
On chasing me out of my my work and I'm
going to continue to treat people
because guess what I'm a doctor
right like you know these many of these
people who got chased out of work were
actually doctors who really did take an
oath and they meant it and they care for
patients and they really did save people
and that's not what most of these people
who ended up making bank
on coven or and I think so just the last
four paragraphs of this Jeffrey Tucker
article in The Brownstone Institute
wraps up nicely I think a lot of what
you're talking about okay
this is again Tucker a guy named Jeffrey
Tucker who I think is the either founder
or the or the or the head of the
Brownstone Institute
all this time while every type of
vicious propaganda was Unleashed on the
world the pro lockdown and pro-mandate
Lobby including fake scientists on fake
studies were benefiting from millions
and billions thrown around by operators
of a Ponzi scheme based on cheating
fraud and 15 billion dollars in
leveraged funds that didn't exist while
its principal actors were languishing a
drug-infested 40 million dollar Villa in
the Bahamas even as they preened about
the virtues of effective altruism and
their pandemic planning Machinery that
has now fallen apart
then the New York Times instead of
decrying this criminal conspiracy for
what it is writes puff pieces on the
founder on how he led his quick growing
company grow too far too fast and now
needs mainly rest bless his heart
the rest of us are left with the bill
for this obvious scam that implausibly
links crypto and covid but just as the
money was based on nothing but puffed
air the damage they have brought on the
world is all too real a Lost Generation
of kids declined life spans Millions
missing from the workforce a calamitous
fall in public health millions of kids
in poverty due to supply chain breakages
19 straight months of falling real
incomes historically High increases in
debt and a dramatic fall in human morale
the world over
so yes we should all be furious and
demand full accountability at the very
least whatever the final truth it is
likely to be far worse within even the
egregious facts listed above it's bad
enough that lockdowns wrecked life and
Liberty to discover that vast support
for them was funded by fraud and fakery
is a deeper level of corruption but not
even the most cynical among us could
have imagined
well you're not cynical
but you did imagine it
you and imagine is the wrong word here
you did you did you did see it coming at
some level you know to some degree and
it you know as it was happening you did
predict it and that's what this time
traveling money printer
it's a set of words together but this
time traveling money printer concept of
yours is is getting at well there's one
more thing it's getting at unfortunately
this believe it or not it gets far worse
soon if we are not wise about at least
figuring out whether this is going on
and getting the to the bottom of FDX and
I believe that in some sense the game
you were about to watch unfold and I
will say we have predicted the middle
ground Scramble with respect to covet
and we have now seen so many versions of
it that you know that prediction uh has
done very very well this is another
prediction like that what are we about
to see
and one thing we are about just I don't
know what you're about to say but I hope
you're wrong me too oh God yes totally
let's hope I'm wrong okay the prediction
is the prediction is what we are going
to see is a very
studious and careful investigation
designed not to find out what's going on
right to limit the damage and that
behind the scenes I would argue what is
taking place at this moment is
um
uh what is called a Mexican standoff
where 14 people are pointing guns at
each other in different ways and you
know the linkages that have been erected
during the movie are so complex that who
wants to shoot who and then somebody
switches right that thing is happening
behind the scenes because yeah the true
Elites behind schemes like this are not
dummies right they don't go into these
things vulnerable by doing bad stuff and
not having a backup plan so they all
have dirt on each other and so the
question is well who who's going on to
the bus and the some of the people who
should go under the bus can't go under
the bus because if they go under the bus
then they're going to take other people
under the bus more than shades of
Jeffrey Epstein well and don't be
surprised if this turns out to be
connected to whatever the Jeffrey
Epstein thing was yeah but first thing
we're going to see is we are going to
see a
seemingly hopeful uh effort to get to
the bottom of this story by the powers
that be that will in the end amount to
what we got with Enron which was a story
limited to a tragic series of some
things that and that one floor that was
so alarming that one trading floor right
okay we're gonna get we're going to get
another version of it we're gonna get
the blue version of Enron right and
what is really going on will be
protected because it has to be because
if it ever came out wow would the blue
thing come tumbling down right but well
you say that but I I just increasingly
don't believe that there's anything that
could be so amazingly clear and obvious
and reprehensible well uh that here's
what it is that if anything would come
toppling down
um
you know the uh the world economic forum
and their embarrassing little I mean not
personally but you will own nothing and
you will be happy and if you think
carefully about what they're saying yeah
they're not saying we will own nothing
and we will be happy they're saying you
will own nothing and you will be happy
more or less or else that thing
um here's the problem
this story already has
the FDX Story the FTX story has
critically damaged crypto which was
already uh reeling from a somewhat
inexplicable collapse uh in the last
several months let's just assume that
the collapse of the value of crypto is
just a normal correction but the FTX
story has now taken uh crypto and it has
shaken everybody's belief in it okay
and it is there everyone who never
invested in crypto is feeling real smug
right well maybe they should but
um the
problem is that it has kicked open the
door for something that appears to have
been marching forward anyway of its own
accord which is truly frightening in
which most people
um
do not
really fathom yet which is a central
bank digital currency
right now A Central Bank digital
currency
is effectively
something that functions like crypto it
has the advantages of being a a virtual
currency but it has the disadvantages of
being a fiat currency and then it has a
bunch of brand new disadvantages which
is that effectively the money can be
uh
controlled by those who own the
structure and this threatens to
basically erect it's a shortcut to
social credit scores and uh and and just
having it's it's loss of freedom in one
step it is
um it is
totalitarianism in an app and a currency
and
um the threat that this poses to the
values on which the West is built really
could not be overstated and you know
many people have seen this there's a
very good discussion of it between Majid
Nawaz and Joe Rogan on Majid's last yeah
months ago at this point yep yeah
um it's very good and quite predictive
there's also a piece that I'm going to
point people to which I hope they will
look at it's actually it's a volume 2 or
episode 2 of a series both of the items
in the series are excellent and I
believe we talked about volume one many
months ago when it emerged it's called
this pivotal moment
and so Volume 2 is now out
um I will tell you and this will give
you a hint of what's really going on can
you like I have no what is it about like
what's the it is it is a video high
production values that lays out the case
for the fact that these Central Bank
digital currencies are coming that they
are part of a plan that they will be
used to control Behavior they will
effectively be used to reward people and
punish them based on whether or not they
adhere to the kinds of behaviors that
the power structure wants them to adhere
to that it's a social credit score for
the West
um and uh in any case it is well worth a
watch and actually maybe Zach do you
want to show us we've got the beginning
of the intro
to Volume 2 here
yep
in episode one of this series the case
was made that we stand on the threshold
of a radical civilizational change in
which the nature of freedom in
Democratic societies a system we have
lived under for centuries will be
transformed beyond recognition
where we are currently free to live the
lives we choose go where we please and
behave as we wish except where our
actions are prohibited in law under this
new system we will only be allowed to do
the things that we've been given
explicit permission to do
the nature of freedom in Democratic
societies will thus become inverted with
our cherished and hard for freedoms
being transformed into mere privileges
granted to us for compliance in total
unquestioning submission to the edicts
of those who control the system
as unlikely as it may sound the first
critical step in this radical
transformation was the introduction of
vaccine passports for vaccine passports
were just the first internationally
coordinated attempt to roll out a
digital ID platform that itself is
designed to rapidly evolve into a social
credit system similar to the one that
people live under in China today
in this news
so
um it's an excellent piece it lays out
the case very well and I will tell you
ominously that what has happened to this
piece it took off when it was first put
onto YouTube uh over a week ago and then
it hit this phenomenon
um I call molasses
where suddenly the growth of something
that is apparently getting people's
attention just stops right where it hits
us the level of viscosity of the system
changes what's more YouTube seems to
have put some sort of a strange
limitation on this uh object that
Corrals how it is viewed so anyway it's
not surprising given what YouTube has
done to us
um to Matt orphalia to others it is not
surprising that YouTube would do what it
could to limit the reach of this piece I
would ask Dark Horse viewers and
listeners
to watch it to give it serious
consideration I would suggest going back
to episode one as well and checking that
one out and
um sharing it which doesn't mean you
have to agree with every element of the
case but I think the case is well worth
airing her
um
and the last thing I'll say is
I believe that what we've said here
today what's laid out in this pivotal
moment episodes one and two also
suggests something very important about
what's going on at Twitter and there's a
lot of everybody seems to think they
know what's going on and lots of people
will argue you know Elon is cynical and
you're all too dumb to see it and things
like this the death of Twitter was
predicted a couple nights ago where it
was supposed to go offline because too
many people
had walked off the job of course it
didn't
um in any case I would say people are
walking off the job or people being
fired well
uh musk gay musk gave them an ultimatum
okay um and he basically said he
outlined what Twitter 2.0 was gonna be
and what it sounded like you know I'm
obviously not uh a Silicon Valley person
but what it sounded to me like was that
what he was trying to do was build a
startup in the ashes of Twitter 1.0 to
make Twitter 2.0 which frankly
sounds pretty cool right if you could
get that kind of burn the Midnight Oil
enthusiasm for building something that
the world needs if you could get that
thing inside a well-established entity
like Twitter having gotten rid of all
sorts of people who weren't really into
it
yeah I mean I think
knowing the university environment a
hell of a lot better than that than the
business environment the Silicon Valley
environment you know you see
you see these initiatives start up you
know institutes and initiatives and
programs and stuff within school you
know schools start up within
universities and you know branch and you
know they they do they they can be
exciting and wonderful but as you and I
have been talking about for for years
and as is well known to Smart historians
and many others
the skill set and energy associated with
uh with with startup or with you know
winning an actual interaction uh is
different from maintaining something
that is coherent that those are very
rarely the same skill sets of the same
people right they're not but I mean
that's part of why what he's proposing
is exciting is that he's not really
talking about doing this with the same
people who were keeping the lights on at
Twitter that this you know one way to
yeah but my you know my point is not oh
well you just need to keep those same
people and make it work not at all I
think um in general and you know again
and I've seen intimation is that a lot
of the a lot of the losses on the tech
sector right now the losses of jobs are
actually from like HR and you know
diversity equity and inclusion teams
like good good you know get rid of them
like these this this was the part of it
that wasn't functioning anyway
um but if fundamentally
um you know startup growth you know the
growth moment and the maintenance moment
which is much more than a moment
requires different sets of skills and
different kinds of people than trying to
trying to maintain uh you know this
thing this you know growth and
acceleration and always something
different on the horizon forever
cannot you know that can't be done it
can't be done right but I don't think
that that's what's going on I think what
you're watching is somebody well and
look there's multiple interpretations of
what's going on right some people are
you know their point is look you're
looking at a cynical actor and you're
just too naive to get it and maybe
that's true but I I don't think so I
think if I'm reading the Tea Leaves of
Twitter correctly what you have is
somebody who has made some interesting
moves that have gotten rid of a lot of
people who weren't on board with what he
was trying to do anyway
that he has the advantage of you know a
benevolent dictator of Twitter and you
know what people
don't you know the
benevolent dictator sounds like an
oxymoron
because people believe that absolute
power corrupts absolutely which I have
always argued is not correct that
whatever but power does is it selects
for corruption and so when people end up
with huge amounts of power they tend to
be very corrupt
it does not mean that somebody who had
power and aspired to something couldn't
use it honorably that they would find
themselves corrupted by it and so look I
may be wrong maybe I am being naive but
I don't think so I think what's going on
is that actually look there's lots of
stuff I think he's doing wrong
but
and he freely says so he says hey we're
going to do a bunch of wrong stuff at
Twitter it's coming you can guarantee it
right that's part and parcel of what
he's up to but I think what he's doing
is something that's evolutionarily wise
which is this is
a new evolutionary phase right that in
effect
he is
he's doing something that you and I have
talked about might be part of an
institution that really worked where it
you know had to reboot itself rather
than corporations that become old and
take on you know a risk aversion because
you know because they're so huge right
something that was able to bootstrap its
way back into that growth phase maybe
periodically rather than try to continue
in the growth phase forever
um makes a lot of sense
but anyway my point about it here is is
different it is because zero is a
special number because we have a
landscape in which a time traveling
money printer is plausible because we
have no mechanism for figuring out
what's coming on our own right we don't
have a newspaper we don't have a
university we don't have science
journals they're all corrupted because
we have that bad landscape Twitter
becomes a place that actually allows
those who have retained their capacity
to think and the courage to say what's
true out loud and are not participating
in the corruption it gives them a place
to air what they've got and it doesn't
mean it's not going to be tremendously
noisy and it doesn't mean there's not
going to be really awful stuff on
Twitter undoubtedly there will be but
the question really is
is this guy really trying to create a
place that is an exception to the rules
that have ruined every other Institution
I still have not seen the data point
that says that's not what's going on and
to the extent that it is what's going on
if we do want to get ahead of whoever it
is that runs the the time traveling
money printer and that has planned a
central bank digital currency to keep us
all Corral if we want to get ahead of
that this is the best game in town right
this is our best play and if it turns
out that musk is cynical that's a huge
problem because we really don't have an
alternative
okay I don't see it if there is one uh I
get
simultaneously uh immediately tired of
talking about Twitter at all and social
media at all
and I also recognize that to my enduring
surprise
when I am trying to figure out what is
happening on some subject
if I duck that go it or Google it or go
to the New York Times or NPR or CNN or
wapo or fox or any you know in any of
the Legacy media sites
I get less interesting and reliable news
less quickly than I do if I do some
relatively careful searches on Twitter
and that's that is a bizarre state to
find ourselves in it it is two things
right it is a measure of how
dysfunctional all of the things that are
supposed to allow you to figure out
what's going on are and it is also an
indication that Twitter despite still
doesn't make sense to me right if you
proposed Twitter to me you said here's
what we're gonna do I would say that's
not going to work nobody's going to do
that well it's also
um
much as you began this this episode by
talking about uh something that Peter
Thiel had said at some lecture about
money having really two different
purposes
Twitter has at least two different
functions whether or not you know
purpose may not be the right word here
but you know it it reads and I certainly
read it before I was on it before I ever
joined it in 2017 as you know a social
media site this is where you go to
um to talk about yourself to share your
stuff with the world to you know post
things that are interested to you and to
find other people who are interested in
the same things and to maybe talk back
and forth with them and like
like if that's what you want to do I
guess and it's going to be valuable to
some people and but this other thing
that we're talking about it doing is
actually totally distinct that I find
you know I I because of what we do we're
both I you know I end up on it and
posting things and to some degree
keeping track of how all those things do
and I'm happier in any week when I've
never gone on it in that in that form it
just it just it's not it's it's not good
for consciousness
but in those weeks when I've never
posted anything
gone to you know or
but I've gone and looked for some you
know news thing gone to pursue a news
story I don't react the same way and it
is interesting and it is valuable and
you don't have to get dragged into like
the personal side of it like the social
like oh how how does how does this
universe view me like no you can do this
even if you're logged in as yourself but
you know better if you're not
um but you can you can use this as a an
actual media site that's not a social
media site and uh and that I think I
would guess is what musk is sort of
alluding to with regard to the I can't
remember exactly what you said he said
but basically that this is going to be
the you know the the news source that we
all use you said he said something like
that yeah he said that I'm trying to
remember exactly but it was something to
the effect that Twitter
um was doing far better as a mechanism
for crowdsourcing information about
what's going on than any of the major
news sources and you've said the same
thing I 100 agree it shouldn't be that
way yeah right we should be able to have
a newspaper but apparently we can't but
I guess it it will be a tougher cell
I'm still skeptical and I you know and I
I am I feel that I am the most skeptical
of social media like anyone I've ever
met
and and I'm on Twitter and I've done
both of these things and I see how much
this is like necessary and sometimes
interesting and often a Time suck almost
entirely and that this thing is actually
whoa surprising oh my God it's actually
a good news source and yet still I find
myself going oh that's Twitter uh why
would I want Twitter for [ __ ] sake
right so I I'm it's going to be a
tougher sell for people if you know if
even I don't quite believe it and I feel
like I'm I I should I should believe it
more than anyone because I've
experienced it yeah I guess what I would
say is I actually think it's a
[Music]
um
it's a moment to
override your instincts with respect to
it because you know I can absolutely see
why it deserves to be discounted as a
result of the fact that it is social
media and social media is itself
um
net negative and so powerfully so
on the other hand
to the you know it's a little bit like
um I don't know what would the analogy
be but uh
you know in in the Apollo 13 situation
right where you've got astronauts and
they're going to die and there are
certain number of objects on the
spacecraft and you have to configure
them into a filter that gets over the
problem
the point is
okay I don't know that the people who
started Twitter had any clue what they
were building and it's certainly a mixed
bag but to the extent that no other
property can sustain a truth-seeking
mechanism and Twitter falls into the
hands of somebody who looks like they're
interested in facilitating that I guess
I would say
you know we are in no position to be
picky about the fact that it's a social
media site because at some level if the
people who remember how to think are
going to have to gather somewhere and
nobody else is going to have them then
Twitter it is
I mean I think I I either you're not
hearing me or you're talking to everyone
else because I have said look I'm I'm
sort of the living realization that
although it's also the social media
thing which I don't think is healthy for
people if that is the thing that's
necessary or in this case in this
version of the universe we have come to
live in
um then it is it is paired inextricably
with an actual effectively and a a news
it's not an organization it's it's an
aggregator yeah uh then then so be it
and you know and and
yes do you all do all the actual fact
checking like actual fact checking not
like one of those professional fact
Checker people do
um on anything you find there as you
would for anything
um but do not start with a personal
discounting of like oh well I found it
on Twitter so I don't know I like that
that that is an unnecessary discounting
that that shouldn't happen at the
beginning of of having found something
on that site as opposed to
kept CNN like really you're gonna prefer
the stuff that that is going to come out
of the one of the mainstream sources I
don't think so all right well I would
say one other thing I think I am a
little bit talking to you I'm also
talking to them and what I'm responding
to something that I am seeing which is
we don't know what musk is up to right
I think most people have not understood
the gravity of the situation and the
paucity of alternatives
think if I look at everything musk has
said and tweeted I think he does
understand why Twitter is important and
I think he does know roughly what he's
trying to create and if that's true then
what he should be getting from us is the
benefit of the doubt all right we should
be approaching
with
let's put it this way I think part of
what is being marshaled against him is
an attempt to create an environment in
which people that he's trying to help uh
respond by hating him and I think he's
pretty good at ignoring that I think
whether it's autism or whatever it is
that he's actually capable of tuning out
that uh thing that would capture almost
anybody else's attention in that spot
and that we would be wise
if we agree that we don't have a better
plan and that this plan might be what it
appears to be then in fact we should be
trying to help by
um
being open to the possibility that it is
what it looks like it is well I think I
think we need to save this for another
conversation because I think we're just
talking past each other I don't know
what the plan is I don't know what it
appears to be like I haven't been paying
much attention so I think you are
imagining that everyone else is in your
head and going like oh well is this the
planner is this not the plans like I
don't know what the plan is supposed to
be so I'm not saying I don't think the
plan is what it is I'm just saying
from you know from well before
must took over Twitter my sense was oh
actually this works as a news aggregator
this is not a social media site and a
story this works as a news aggregator
this is much more than what it's
advertised as and it was getting worse
at that because of the censorship
because uh so many accounts
um both people and institutions are
being shut down for saying things that
the woke ideologues who are behind the
scenes having been hired to moderate
content were it being you know we're
saying no you can't say that no you
can't say this so it was getting less
good at that but it was really good at
this thing which no one was claiming it
was good at and yet that is what it was
so so I you know that that in and of
itself is interesting and uh and
potentially sort of where where media
goes given that
apparently you can't trust editors
because all the you know pretty much all
of the main
um mainstream media organizations have
been toppled by editors hiring
idiots I guess like that's the wrong
word
for some of them but you know just you
know a lot of let a bunch of people in
the door who then take over and and it's
gone and I guess I mean that does we
really
do need to finish and we have a cat here
this week and I promised cats last week
and people really wanted cats this week
so I do want to talk about all right the
story but but this is actually a decent
segue to talk very briefly about another
thing that I did want to talk about this
week
um which is an editor Emeritus and
columnist for the Toronto Sun Lori
Goldstein who I've never heard of before
and I may be pronounce mispronouncing
his last name
um hat tip to him uh for on Twitter
pointing me to the College of Physicians
and surgeons in Ontario their coveted 19
facts for Physicians and I can't show my
screen with our current setup so I
cannot show you guys this but on
November 18th which is yesterday they
updated their facts their their
frequently asked questions for
Physicians and I just want to read you a
couple of what the College of Physicians
and surgeons in Ontario was recommending
that doctors say to people to the
patients question patients are asking me
to write notes supporting a medical
exemption from covid-19 vaccines what do
I need to know
the answer is long and there's a number
of paragraphs and here are two
paragraphs not contiguous in the
original that the College of Physicians
and surgeons in Ontario says the doctors
should say to patients who are coming in
asking for coveted vaccine exemptions
quote
generally speaking there are very few
acceptable medical exemptions to the
Copa 19 vaccination examples include an
allergist immunologist confirmed severe
allergy or anaphylactic reaction to a
previous dose of a covid-19 vaccine or
to any of its components that cannot be
mitigated or diagnosed episode of
myocarditis or pericarditis after
receipt of an mRNA vaccine
so that's one
uh the other paragraph not contiguous
it is also important that Physicians
work with their patients to manage
anxieties related to the vaccine and not
enable avoidance behavior for example
for extreme fear of needles
trypanophobia they usefully give a big
word there in case you weren't sure or
other cases of serious concern
responsible use of prescription
medications and a referral to
psychotherapy may be available options
overall Physicians have a responsibility
to allow their patients to be properly
informed about vaccines and not have
those anxieties empowered by an
exemption
so what if you're afraid of toxins
rather than needles so if you don't want
our experimental medical treatment we're
going to either give you a different
medical treatment or call you crazy and
scared and have you talked to someone
about that so you can get uncrazy and
unscared and get our experimental
medical treatment right they have
defined out of possibility the fact that
your trepidations might be based on the
fact that this is dangerous right and
this remind remember is the College of
Physicians and surgeons in Ontario not a
fly-by-night organization although we
can hope that maybe they will so one
more quote from the site
uh one more one more frequently Asked
question from the site again updated
yesterday this is not months or years
ago this is updated yesterday
I've read about some drugs that might
prove beneficial in treating covet 19.
should I be prescribing these drugs as a
precautionary measure can I prescribe
them for myself or family
no
many of these drugs have an intended use
in prescribing them as a precautionary
measure has or may contribute to drug
shortages compromising care for others
should these or other drugs prove useful
in combating covid-19 their use will
need to be carefully managed to support
those who need them the most
foreign
with the together trial still being
promoted as the evidence that for
instance iverbectin does not work and
really I wish the together trial had
some sort of thing we could burn an
effigy or like I could break it out with
like a head on a stock like this thing
is dead
this is not what it seemed we know that
from so many angles now and here we have
as of yesterday mid-november 2022 the
College of Physicians and surgeons in
Ontario telling its members how to
respond to patients or each other when
they say well but aren't there some
things I could use to treat code but no
don't do that you're going to contribute
to drug shortages also we don't know if
those work
all right
I need two more minutes before we get to
cats because you're uh last bit there
has
closed the the picture pretty pretty
well great
Twitter
like all such experiments is an
evolutionary environment
as the other evolutionary environments
succumbed to a kind of control that
prevented uh reality from rising above
noise
it proved an environment in which it was
very hard to keep the truth Secret
what emerged was
absurd censorship to cover that Gap in
other words you've got an evolutionary
environment
initially it's people talking to each
other about they don't know what
professionals end up there and start
effectively fact checking the world and
saying that's not really true here's
here's what's going on here's the
references right it becomes an
environment that surely is not what its
inventors had in mind
they have to go great guns on aggressive
censorship throw people off who are
highly credentialed who are in a
position to say that's not true here's
how you know right so they're trying to
turn it into a noisy environment rather
than a signal-rich environment through
heavy-handed censorship it then falls
into other hands and those other hands
the plan I think is to restore its
nature So the plan by musk yeah is to
restore the capacity for sense making to
evolve in this context which it
naturally tends to do which you're
saying you've used it for right you
wouldn't think of it as a place to as a
news aggregator or a place to find out
what's actually taking place because I
find myself like I'll do searches in
other places and then go to Twitter and
try there like okay right now I can find
it and so this you know it's like a a
little
um microcosm of social sociality in
which it's not that it's fundamental
nature is truth seeking but it's a place
that is hospitable to those who wish to
do truth seeking yes and so I think that
is the plan and to the extent that
that's the plan I feel like we should
all get behind it and vocally so because
zero is a special number and this is the
only thing that stands between us and
zero
all right
and I think we can go full circle
because I imagine the founders of if not
social media than the internet
thought that it was mostly going to be
videos of cats and it was for quite some
time so let's talk about cats all right
we have only one cat on on screen here
and he's kind of sleepy so he's not
going to do a lot of uh
okay that was that was not bad yes on
cue decent yeah
um but a little too dark for the camera
to pick him up super well here but
um Okay so
there's a new piece of research it's not
impressive but the topic is an
interesting one so uh I I didn't want to
have spent so much time sort of like
leading up to this because it's really
not a great paper and there's another
paper that it references that's even a
worse paper but it has such a great
conclusion I just I'm going to talk us
through in both of their cases why the
methods are kind of ridiculous and so we
don't know what we know like we don't
know that we know what they think we
know now uh but but still the topic is
basically one of
what do any of those kinds of
individuals that we speak to
who don't have the same linguistic
capacity that we do understand of us and
so there is you know in in this area of
research there are various acronyms of
course because you gotta once you have
an area of research you got to start
with creating the acronyms so as to you
know sort of keep people out but you
have like infant directed speech like
how does infant directed speech differ
from adult directed speech I would never
let an infant direct a speech how does
dog directed speech differ from adult
directed speech how does Captain
directed at then yeah exactly
um and this there's a lot of research of
course on infant direct to speech and
you know everyone has been a parent has
noticed that they do or do not like we
we didn't modulate our speech nearly as
much as most people do when our kids
were very very young
um I think we probably do much more for
our animals yes for non-human animals
than we did for our our human animals
when they were very young uh and and yet
we know for instance that uh from
historical work speech directed at
companion animals shares aspects of
speech directed infants specific
specifically with regard to hyper
articulation
right shorter utterances more
repetitions elevated pitch and increased
pitch variation
okay so all of those things you will
recognize if you've ever had a baby or a
dog or a cat or you know even a fish if
you're that kind of person but probably
you don't talk to your fish that way
some people might but again
hyperarticulation shorter utterances
more repetitions elevated pitch and
increased pitch variation all are things
that have been noted as being true facts
true facts about the companion animals a
reference that no one will get except
for Toby if he's watching
uh Z Frank
in a video called
it's about three oh there are a lot of
true facts videos
a long day
okay
um so
that are true of the way that people
talk when they're talking to babies in
particular and to some degree to
companion animals has been supported by
a lot of action good research
um the research just came out last month
in journal uh animal cognition
it's got three authors
they're French and it's called
discrimination of cat-directed speech
from Human directed speech in a
population of indoor companion cats
so the question is
um
can
can cats distinguish between speech
that's directed at them versus speech
that is not directed at them and this is
a question that you feel somewhat
strongly about
yes for the record my position is that
cats don't even know their names and
anything beyond that is wasted okay but
but knowing your name may be a different
and like lateral question to do you know
you're being spoken to
okay and I I agree that there's
something interesting here especially in
light of the fact which I believe is a
fact that uh domestic cats that are
vocal are vocal with their people but
they are not vocal with each other in
the absence of people and I think
hypothesis they're not going to be vocal
with strangers the same way they're
going to be vocal with their people they
don't do a lot of cat calling
sorry I think yeah yeah yeah
um
so
also from just past research which is
two more interesting things that I think
I didn't pursue all of the different
pieces of research and to assess how
good they were but two other results not
from this research that just came out in
animal cognition last month are that
people raised the pitch of their voices
more when talking to puppies than
talking to adult dogs
so the like I'm talking to a youngin
thing gets added to itself when you're
talking to a puppy who doesn't yet know
versus a dog who kind of does okay and
um also people modulate their pitch more
when talking to dogs than to cats
okay as as if and this isn't to say
necessarily that that's apt but as if
the people at least imagine that the the
dog may be interpreting more accurately
than the cat does so like you wouldn't
modulate your pitch either you would
think that the cat can understand you
completely right which is then you you
got some issues to work at or you don't
think the cat's understanding you at all
in which case you don't modulate your
pitch really but you will modulate your
pitch for your dog which you imagine
could understand you partially but not
fully just like you would do if you were
talking to a baby all right two
observations one you could interpret
that either way right you could either
people uh and I don't think this is true
but either people uh imagine their cats
are more comprehending and the dog needs
the exaggerated pitch to get it yeah
talking to a cat is more like talking to
a 12 year old and talking to a dog's
talking to a two-year-old not so much
yeah
talking to a cat is more like talking to
a tree but I was gonna say a sponge I
don't and I don't mean that at all like
I I actually I'm I I fall on the other
side of this but well look there are a
lot of reasons to talk to your animals
some of them have nothing to do with
your animal knowing what you're talking
about sure of course
um but uh yeah practice your speech on
them sometimes
well I think giving voice to what they
might be thinking is a useful exercise
oh it's wonderful yes but um I had
another point and I've now Maddie do you
remember
she
um oh the other thing I was going to say
is it doesn't necessarily have anything
whatsoever to do with what people think
in fact to the extent
the dogs do get it and they do they get
a lot of human language they don't
necessarily know what you mean but they
they interpret a lot of stuff to the
extent that that's true they may be in
effect training you in other words to
the extent that you exaggerate your
meaning when you're talking to your dog
the dog may be more successful at doing
what you want it to do and so you would
become inadvertently trained to do that
whereas your cat because it doesn't do
what you want it to do does not train
you to alter your modulation
Oh I thought well I think you're
conflating two things there like can
they under you know are they getting you
to effectively Slow Down slow down and
Hyper articulate and all of this in
order that they can learn more about how
to understand you so that they can do
what you want so there's a do I
understand you and will I do what you
want question and we have to separate
those because cat's not going to do what
you want right right but does a cat
understand you that's that's the
question we're trying to tease apart
here and it's it is harder because you
can't basically do like a like just just
run this maze for me and like a dog
might look at you funny be like why
would I do that but okay and a cat's
like no I'm not I'm not gonna right it
could understand completely what you
want yeah it would affect its Behavior
not at all yeah so you so you're gonna
need to be a little clever in your
design of of how you can figure out if
um
if your animal is responding to you and
we know from a lot of previous research
that yes infants are responding and
learning from adult language the more
the older they get dogs are responding
to human language too to a remarkable
idea but a remarkable degree rather but
what about cats it hasn't been looked at
in part perhaps because they don't feel
like uh collaborating and so like how
would you know
so this new paper uh
again really small study
uh the methods quote 19 cats were
recruited to the study out of them 16
cats parentheses nine males and seven
females completed the whole study end
quote I'm like what the other cats have
better things to do what happens when
okay okay so three cats I don't think so
I don't think so so it's a tiny little
study
it's also it's indoor cats they're
living with vet students and studio
apartments okay so it's really narrow in
terms of what kind of cats are being
asked to
um
to to basically respond either
to to
four kinds of speech I guess it's going
to have been and I I was paying more
attention to the other one but I think
it was
um owner speech
to other people
owner speech to direct it to cats
stranger speech to other people like
just ambient speech and stranger speech
directed at the cat so we you know the
cat is hearing four different kinds of
voices two of uh two different humans
um one human whom they know well and two
different situations of the humans
talking one in which they're just
talking not to the cat at all and one in
which they're talking to
um through the cat and the only one of
those four situations there was one
situation in which the cats responded
and it was of course the one in which
the owner is talking to the cat and they
do show a response so okay small 16 cats
again three had something else to do in
durcats living you know with vet
students all of this but they did find
that cats actually responded uh
noticeably to owners talking to cats but
not in any of the not human voices in
any of the other situations
interesting of true okay I actually I
believe that yeah
um so you know cats is a conclusion
again small study is that human that
cats do discriminate between human
speech um that is ambient human speech
that is directed to them but only when
it's from a person who they know
and and you know I'd love to see if like
you know if in our situation where our
cats have four people who they know
really well and other people
um I I think absolutely our cats respond
to our voices and not to some random
person who comes it's like hey Kitty
I'll be like what no I'm not
you got kibble but right
um but then I also wanted to share
a 2002 paper
it's really ridiculous in terms of the
method so I have to walk us through that
first but because the conclusion is so
fantastic I hope it holds up if ever the
right study is done
so
what was done is they've got
undergraduate psych students interacting
with a cat whose real name the psych
students don't know they've been given a
fake name so the cat can't respond to
its name being used it's kind of funny
okay engaging how human speech and also
human feelings about cats affect how the
humans uh will interact with them and so
they're not they're just giving some
like toys some enrichment stuff they're
they can't touch the cat and so that's
also like some cats will be like yeah
touch me like oh you're not going to
touch me what am I why am I paying any
attention to you right but the study was
trying to get at like what what is a
person's opinion about whether or not
they like cats does that affect whether
or not the cat is interacting with them
and also what kinds of things that
people might say two cats gets cats to
interact with them in this case it's all
strangers
the the dramatic failing of this study
is that they literally used one cat
who's let me say
um
I can't remember what the cat's actual
name is but the cat was going by
whiskers in the study okay and um wait
no I do have it I have it highlighted
here see if I can find it sorry guys oh
here we go um
in the methods under feline Confederate
a two-year four-month-old female gray
tortoiseshell cat served in the study
she was unfamiliar to all of the
participants although the cat actually
was named Tabitha she was referred to as
whiskers throughout the study to ensure
that her responses were not based on
hearing her real name it was also
thought that using a gender-neutral name
would help reduce gender-based
expectations of the cat's Behavior
okay that's all fine except like one cat
right like like you can't do this
without cap because cats are singular
cats have personalities we have no idea
if the result of this study are because
whiskers no Tabitha had particular
feelings about particular kinds of
humans because probably she did so
all that is to say I have no idea if
this will hold up but the results of
this study
were twofold one is not very surprising
um women who self-report that they like
cats are more likely to have cats
unknown to them choose to spend time
with them
okay whereas men who self-report that
they like cats we're not better able to
attract Tabitha
to them
cats it's not it's not cats it's not
cats at all uh and again it's you know
undergrad it's undergraduate psych
students right so it's this very narrow
piece of piece of reality
um but cats
cat
or less are I see I insist on using the
plural because they did too until I went
back and carefully read the methods like
no it's not a cat's situation it's
really not but okay cat is less likely
to approach strange men whose speech has
a high degree of imperatives like come
here and don't do that which is to say
my
my conclusion the way that I would
phrase that and they didn't is cats
avoid strange men who give orders
shouldn't we all so cats cat Tabitha
representing all cats and I would say
maybe should be representing like all
mammals avoid strange men who give
orders and maybe if we all just kind of
like started there and went like okay
let's just figure out if I can know you
better before I accept your imperatives
to come here and do that then then we
could maybe accomplish more in the world
yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah
um so that's that's that's all I got
so should this ever be done with
multiple cats more than one Tabitha more
than one Tabitha that you're hoping that
result will hold up yeah yeah I I did
they they didn't correct for whether men
were more likely to give orders I mean
they had imperatives being given by both
women and men yeah yeah I don't think it
was equal you know they didn't go they
did not
um they did not tell the human they
didn't call them Confederates human
participants human participants in
advance what kinds of ways to interact
with with whiskers
um they just let them interact but there
were um so what they found I think
um
and there were also there were cat
owners and non-cat owners among them
there were men and women among them
um somehow it was only male participants
who dated whose data had to be deleted
we aren't told why
um but uh there were imperatives uh that
were given by women and the cats
the cat did not preferentially avoid the
women giving orders just the men the
strange men giving well that's
interesting I uh I admit that in
addition to the male female comparison
I'm also interested in within males uh
Canadian and not Canadian you know
because I'm imagining that Canadian
males are not that great at giving
orders except for Justin Trudeau there
seems to be an exception though he may
be Cuban laughs
I think we're done I think that's
excellent yes
so exactly if we could let you know
Tabitha may have the wisdom of her
generation now this is from 2002 tablet
is probably unfortunately no longer with
us uh but I imagine that we could find a
tablets after 2022 and find that
avoiding strange men who give orders is
in fact not the best way forward either
through a pandemic or not
um that's right yeah especially with all
the lockdowns to have at the two may
have groked that in fact taking such
orders is really not a good thing really
not a good idea yeah all right so uh
maybe I would I imagine that I will go a
little bit deeper into the infant
directed speech dog directed speech
caterated speech literature and I think
there's just not very much on the
cataracted speech literature hence this
being sort of the best that I could find
but
um
I I'm I'm pleased that I feel I think
that you were already there but I feel
like I've pulled you a little bit
towards my position on the question only
by being explicit about like do cats
understand you know do do cats
understand that they are being spoken to
when it is by someone whom they know and
uh you know that that first paper that
was better done than this 2002 paper the
one that was just published last year uh
suggested yes but it was very small I
think that I think that result will hold
up well look I don't have any doubt
about this actually I mean you know uh
that I uh when I need to find the cat
for the feeding yes um that I Whistle
and that by whistling priority which
you've never referred to either of the
hymns as the cat the cat yeah
um but uh that by whistling before
feeding the whistling then produces the
cat because the cat wants to eat and so
it an inadvertent version of this
undoubtedly happens because a person
talking to other people in the
environment of the cat does not suggest
that food is about to happen but a
person talking to the cat probably
precedes the cat getting fed fairly
frequently and so it wouldn't be
surprising
if the animal had detected that there
was something about that kind of speech
that means I should hang around the
kitchen and
um and talking about carne asada does
not bring out the cat but bringing the
carne asada out of the refrigerator does
bring out does bring out the cat for
many comprehensible reasons so yes I
just don't think the cat has any idea
what the hell we're talking about even
when we are talking about the cat
well at the moment he's sleeping so it's
not a fairy it's not a fair question
that is true yes all right it is it is
finally we've we've been on here talking
to you guys at you guys for a little
while we apologize for
we apologize for all of it uh not the
part that wasn't our fault though uh we
are not going to do a q a this week
which means two weeks running we're not
next week right now the question asking
period at my uh my patreon is open so so
go there if you're if you're a patron 11
or up or join ask a question next week
we're gonna do four count them four live
streams we're gonna do live stream 151
of Dark Horse uh on time
and they're under budget and under
budget are we okay Zach
okay okay
I don't know if it's gonna be under
budget because I don't I feel like I'm
I'm in charge of the budget and I'm not
sure we're under budget at this point
um and the Q a we are definitely going
to have it we're going to have three
questions from the Discord at the top of
the hour next week and then we're gonna
address as many of the questions from
this week and last week and some from
next week in the Q a afterwards that'll
be on Saturday after American
Thanksgiving next week I don't know what
day that's going to be November
my uh 26th and then the 27th at 9 45 a.m
Pacific we are going to do a one hour
paid ad free mostly about products like
holiday gift episode talking about some
stuff that that we like that might also
help you with your holiday shopping if
you do that sort of thing it might help
you even if you don't do that sort of
thing and then we're going to take a
break and then for patrons of mine only
we're going to be doing our two hour
private q a which is always on the last
Sunday of the month at 11 A.M Pacific
it's a lot of fun it's small enough that
we can watch the chat and interact with
people and uh encourage you to join us
there although that's going to be a lot
of time with us if you watch all of
those we'll be tired of us by the end
hopefully you won't be
for now anything else you want to say
before
all right
until next time be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
foreign
[Music]
[Music]